today the Federal Open Market Committee
maintained the target range for the
federal funds rate at one-quarter to
one-half percent economic growth was
relatively weak late last year and early
this year business investment outside of
energy was particularly weak during the
winter and appears to have remained so
into the spring in addition growth in
household spending slowed noticeably
early in the year despite solid
increases in household income as well as
relatively high levels of consumer
sentiment and wealth the pace of
improvement in the labor market appears
to have slowed markedly job gains in
April and May are estimated to have
averaged only about 80 thousand per
month on a more positive note every
jerilee earnings increased two and a
half percent over the past 12 months a
bit faster than in earlier years and a
welcome indication that wage growth may
finally be picking up we continue to
expect that the evolution of the economy
will warrant only gradual increases in
the federal funds rate we expect the
rate to remain for some time below
levels that are anticipated to prevail
in the longer run because headwinds
weighing on the economy mean that the
interest rate needed to keep the economy
operating near its potential is low by
historical standards these headwinds
which include developments abroad
subdued household formation and meagre
productivity growth could persist for
some time but if they gradually fade
over the next few years as we expect
then the interest rate required to keep
the economy operating at an even keel
should move higher as well
you